have you ever had a person in your life
that kept bullshitting you for a very
long time everyone's had somebody right
and some of us have been that person to
others you know what's the most
important question to ask about that I
think the most important question to ask
is this how long did it take you to
figure out that that person was biessing
you was it three months was it six
months twelve months two years some
three five years how long was it C it
doesn't matter how long it was because
the most interesting thing about
bullshitters is eventually everyone
figures at their BS n everybody does and
if you choose to become an entrepreneur
you lose the permission to the
world you know why because in the world
of business everything is transparent
because everything is linked to numbers
it all comes down to how many calls you
make how bad you hustle how hard you
work how late you stay how early you
wake up how many books you read how much
you develop yourself the relationships
you're meeting the biz that all comes
down to the effort you put in upfront
and if you do that three five ten years
later the world realizes you were legit
and if you don't you won't even give
yourself a chance to make it as an
entrepreneur so my challenge is very
simple be true to yourself figure out
what you're not doing why you're afraid
of doing it and start doing it today
because if you don't you may end up
being that bullshitter in someone else's
life
you